alter schwede das zitat es ist wirklich
hart die geschichte lautet ich habe
meinen freunden gesagt dass ich ein
verfehlt und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute sind wir hier
mit der marke hat mir eure peinlichsten
geschichte eigentlich sehr nett
lesen sie heute mit marc rich und schau
mal so waffe dabei sogar die marke von
red hat ist auch englisch
ich habe hier auf meinem rechner eure
antworten vor mir maxime ich deswegen
wird max ist blind und leistet bekommen
ich lebe auch live durch und wir sagen
wir legen los mit einsendungen immer ein
spiel gehabt und fenster gemacht erzählt
eine geschichte
und ich stehe einfach zwei zeilen drin
ganz kurz habe einfach meinen lehrer
angekotzt so herrlich über schule
gegangen bin als sie noch ein baby krank
war alles klar der daumen gepeilt guten
morgen guten krank kopfschmerzen
okay der verein sendung ein von 250
versöhner bitte vor und natürlich nicht
alle im heutigen videoseite noch wieder
haben wollt dann auf jeden fall was da
wir können auch immer noch ein senden
wenn eure geschichte auch mal aufwachen
soll einfach den ersten link neben den
zweiten blick nämlich werbung klicken
dafür das formular und kennt derzeit
schreiben die nächste geschichte sogar
nur eine zeit und zwar eine mutter hat
mich beim masturbieren + vorne gucken
erwischt und dann fegte geschichte
wieder 100 teile aber alter schwede
dass die fahrt es ist wirklich hart als
ich kurz mal fest
sieht man das wirklich verzählt dass man
auch weiß hat wegen sich jetzt mal ab
ok als wäre die geschichte lautet ich
habe meinen freunden gesagt dass ich ein
apparat video angesehen habe
[Musik]
wird eine e mail an teilprojekt ein
knapp sein email-system leute deswegen
will ich lieber nicht vor ort ist
zweistufig geschichte mehr als eine
feile mehr als 2000 leute da kann man
fast schon geschichte lautet ich war vor
1 jahr mal bei einer freundin
das ist super einem jahr kann man sich
mit freunden auf jeden fall treffen also
übertreibt nicht dass ich damit sagen
musste dort mal evans bringen
pippi nach miley vor lauter stress
stress habe ich vergessen die klodeckel
aufgeklappten also habe ich dann auf den
klodeckel und auf den boden gefallen
oktober 4 und dem badezimmer vorlege
aufgerechnet war mit ihrer mutter wissen
dass jetzt nichts davon dass wir noch
etwas ich so etwas haben wir noch einer
anderen stadt gewohnt erreichbar festen
freund auf der toilette ein bisschen
bonita zu belüften sehe ich ganz viel
seife und macht wie ins klo möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen
sodann herabgestuft und dann gab es
natürlich richtig viel richtig viel
blabla und kommt an ihm ist es noch mal
so das blatt
ich bin jedenfalls wieder zu hause und
dann die mutter so viel vor
das war die kleine schwester
im gruppe was hast du deinen bart macht
spaß gemacht und ich habe mir in brand
es war eine glückliche familie berg
bringt all das will er hängen lassen
wie gesagt dass ich das nicht geglaubt
im richtiger unmenschen eigentlich
dieses video
ich gehe nicht so falsch weil ich hoffe
dass die späte rache die combo auf
einmal kein bug in deinem kopf
auch hier eine schöne geschichte aus dem
leben ist können ein trick sein ich bin
so ganz vorbei gelaufen und hab halt auf
meinen schwarm gedacht okay und ja
natürlich voll gegen eine tür offen und
die chance für ihr übernächstes jahr
behalten ich bin der wm
die komplette agenda da waren die party
im einkaufszentrum hier und da ist noch
eine glasschiebetür angelaufen als wie
gesagt hause schickt schickt einfach
gegen die glas verlaufen dann denken
richtiger mann
der hätte wenn die glastür auf folgende
geschichte passiert im musikunterricht
meine lehrerin zählte gerade von fünf
runter damit wir mit unseren
instrumenten anfang spielen ja komplette
stille grabes totenstille im
klassenzimmer leer fanta 5 4 3 2 1
und ich hab dann plötzlich richtige
lautlos oder einfach kurz abgesucht von
leuten die ich kann mir die ganzen
sachen wirklich lebendig vorstellen so
schön
4 bevor ich sag dir schwer dfb gewandt
diese geschichten möglich zu ja ich sag
mal im bus und wollte ein foto von einem
gut aussehenden typen schießen um mit
meiner freundin zu schicken ist wie
berichtet laufen die mehrere lagen mit
einem typen gehört dass der wie ein foto
von der media night findet unter dem
schicken oder auch die veranstaltungen
sind garantiert gehört gelassen haben
wir leider hatte ich den blitz an und er
hat mich verwirrt und böse eingefügt das
hat jetzt wirklich vielen leuten glaube
heute redet doch einfach mit menschen
redet oder razzien foto machen dürfte es
wieder so eine story folgen eine story
von liebe und leidenschaft ein mädchen
wäre wenigstes vernetzte folgende
geschichte ich bleibe ich 14 bin
momentan ein lehrer verliebt und ihr
einmal mussten wir etwas wegen einem
auftritt besprechen jeder aus der klasse
musste teamerfolg kommt dann bin ich
gehe hin quatsch ich mich vor allem habe
ich wieder gehen was passiert ich kämpfe
einfach über seine tasche und fall voll
auf die fresse haut op klavierlehrer
wird euch einfach katastrophal bedeutet
du kannst doch mal ein mädel die
einfachen loch in ihr handy schmidt nach
dem foto von dem leben machen ihr mann
hat ihm noch eingeschnitten an der
abwehr ab dem 7
grass hatte fotografieren da stellt sich
mir nur eine frage
willst du mich für mich dass ich hoffe
hoch exakt leute das war von der ersten
folge weg magna besser beschreiben
verlinkt ich muss sagen nicht eine
meiner schlechtesten ideen so ein video
aufzunehmen mart sanken dabei sein
durch gewisse spiel um vom nachbar was
ja klar
dreist weil ein